[Music]
that sounds like a deal which should
take hey Jim oh hey Tyler come on in I'm
sorry you'll have to excuse me my
daughter's wonderful boyfriend has just
come in and surprised me
yes I will talk to you soon okay boy is
it good to see you Jim you're gonna want
to sit down what's going on I just got
to get something off my chest but uh I
know it's gonna hurt you it's gonna hurt
me
your dad our Cindy and I both decided to
go our separate ways
well that sucks but I'm sure you'll went
right back on your feet
Thanks so her money golf on Saturday
still Oh Jim I don't think we can do
that look you're a great guy and all but
are you leaving this isn't easy but I
gotta do what I gotta do so just like
that you're out of my life so sorry
you're the greatest father figure I've
ever had Who am I gonna watch The Fast
and Furious movies maybe
wife she hates those puppies I was
almost about to invite you into my
fantasy football league Jim stop you're
only gonna make it worse I even told all
the guys in the office about you you can
told my boss that I have a son but I was
damn proud you were always more than my
daughter's boyfriend Tyler you were my
best friend and you were mine but the
curtains are closing and it's time for
us to give our final bow don't we
deserve an encore you always were the
dream my Jim I'm gonna miss that about
you
I'm sure Cindy will go out and find
another boyfriend that you'll end up
bonding with you know maybe he'll end up
liking the Discovery Channel or window
treatments just as much as you never
never say never Jim Tyler you're still
here
Cindy hey hey we were um we were just
talking about baseball baseball yeah
okay Tyler I think it's time for you to
go oh yeah yeah
[Music]
you